Okay.
I can't make heads
or tails of this.
What is this for?
Oh, I got that for
biking on the sidewalk,
but because I hadn't
paid my last ticket
for biking on
the sidewalk--
I gotta tell ya, this
is all a mess,
'cause none of this is
necessary or helpful.
Oh, come on, Killian Casey,
C.P.A., I didn't know!
Oh, I didn't know,
Killian.
My final question-- do
you have any dependents?
Uh, I have a lot of
independence, but, um--
I guess I have people
who depend on me, too.
So, no?
Correct.
I think I almost
got this.
Got what?
I think it's, like, some sort
of rocket ship or something.
It's my family.
This magic eye
is your family?
It's a regular
photograph.
I don't know, man.
I don't care if you
believe me or not.
Your refund
comes to $52.
Cha-chang,
cha-chang!
(Killian)
It's combined
State and Federal.
My fee is $125
for the day.
What?
I'm giving you more
than I'm getting back?
That's illegal.
It's not illegal.
You're paying me to do
your taxes for you.
Yeah, but I'm not
gonna go negative
for my taxes
to get done.
I shouldn't have done
them in the first place.
You know what? I think
we're done here.
Why don't you take
your garbage...
and mail it
out yourself.
You're not gonna
mail it?
I thought this was
a one-stop shop.
I came here
for the stamps.
I see it,
it's your family.
Get outta here.
I got it.
Get outta here!
Who yells?
Go! Go!
My purse!
Go!
Get out!
Get outta here!
Give me that!